when drew robinson takes the field
we know he may make it back to major
league baseball or he may not
either way it won't be the challenge of
his lifetime he is a resilient reminder
that anyone can struggle and hurt
and they can also overcome
his story hits hard because it hits home
las vegas is the setting for drew
robinson's rise
his rock bottom his return one of the
promises i made to myself
this time around is just soaking it all
in and
letting all the emotions come out good
or bad and
i'm just so happy to be here in april of
2020
drew's attempt at suicide was
miraculously
not meant to be umc and unlv doctors
repaired him
the community restored him the
ballplayer who lost an eye
saw a vivid purpose as a global advocate
for mental health
and a shot at a comeback the way i did
it
should not be here and i i recognize
that and i
that's another reason why i'm not taking
anything for granted and
trying to live this out the best way
possible it's easy to doubt whether he
can reclaim a career
but clearly this las vegas has mastered
the art of beating the odds
being able to come home and just get
that first
those first reps in front of everybody
was
it was just powerful the story is
cinematic but the strikeouts
still sting when i make a mistake it's
really easy to say that's because i have
one eye but
i have to do a really good job reminding
myself that i made mistakes even when i
had two eyes
so when the new drew rocked his first
hit do you think it was rewarding
hell yes it was even though i told
myself to let it all out i just had to
like really hold back from just like
almost running up through the stands and
giving my family some hugs so
i gave them a nice little point and i
recognized them and they recognized him
as
a competitor with candor and courage
standing in the outfield
and standing for so much more i still
have a lot of work to do i would say and
i know that this is like a never-ending
battle with with some some dark thoughts
but
i've come so far in 13 months so it just
excites me
13 months after he tried to end his
story
we're all better for drew robinson's
brave new beginning
mrs robinson i hope you had a happy
mother's day